if you are looking for something to do
as your self socially distancing and
physically distancing in self isolating
up go to the David Pakman show read it
at david pakman.com slash reddit re d di
t nearly 19,000 of our viewers and
listeners are now participating on our
subreddit some interesting posts I saw
user restless pedestrian posted an
article about Finance ears making a lot
of money off of the pandemic I have been
talking about this more so on the live
streams than on the broadcast show for a
couple of weeks now there is a lot of
money being made on coronavirus you have
of course finance ears and banksters who
are able now especially to start
processing these loans under the
Paycheck protection plan they get 5 0.05
percent commission on every dollar
process paid by the government you can
rack up big profits doing that you've
got the short sellers of different kinds
who at different points bet on the stock
market declining and made money off of
that you have all sorts of different
companies jumping in and making masks
and other things which of course is good
those things are needed but they've
proven to be very profitable endeavors
including when you get a slot
speaking at a coronavirus press
conference like the my pillow trump
sycophant guy Michael in Dell did making
some masks instead of pillows and
getting invited to speak on a national
stage so there are all sorts of
different people that are cashing in on
coronavirus and what we need to
understand is this isn't new every
tragedy every calamity has people who
were able to profit from it sometimes
people are profiting by helping in a
serious and sincere way other times
people are taking advantages of
loopholes or vulnerabilities scamming
people selling things like as you know
silver toothpaste and others claiming
they killed a virus it is nothing new
that there is plenty of money to be made
around tragedies and we are seeing that
happen another interesting discussion on
the reddit is black rien said we should
start making a distinction
between the progressive left and the
populist left pointing out that populism
wants to appeal to ordinary people who
feel their concerns are disregarded
whereas progressivism is a particular
political philosophy supporting social
reform and certain policy ideas I want
to be careful about this for two reasons
number one when we go crazy with how we
name different groups and categorize
different people it's often not useful
at all and is often a distraction and
you know you if you've listened to some
of the pedantic phone calls I will
sometimes get during live calls from
people saying you know I used to be a
civil libertarian but now I am a
moderate and cap or whatever it it gets
us very little it gets us very little
and actually figuring out how society
culture and the economy should go so
here's my one thought populism can be
left or right populism in and of itself
can can be left or right and as the the
this viewer is saying we're
distinguishing between the progressive
left and the populist left I actually
think that populist left implies
progressivism so for me there's not
really a conflict the populist left has
elements of populism with progressive
social policy progressive economic
policy etc I would not overly focus on
these labels check out some of the work
from the new schools
professor Federico Finkelstein who is a
fellow Argentinean he's been a guest on
the program expert in populism
authoritarianism etc let's not go crazy
with the labels and the categorization I
don't think we get much out of it lastly
a bit of good news from the sub reddit
user bag of squares has notified us that
the pandemic has resulted in their mom
becoming a fan of the David Pakman show
pointing out that she previously was a
political sometimes with some anti-obama
sentiment but that she has recently been
on the online media rabbit hole she came
across the David Pakman show and now is
a regular viewer
of the show that's a good thing that's a
good thing and I really I've heard a lot
of those stories actually during the
pandemic a lot of people home and
consuming media they wouldn't otherwise
consume and really great appreciate it
say hi to your mom for me joined the
discussion at david pakman.com slash
read it it's free it's something to do
and you'll see you'll see me on there
you'll see producer pat they're very
very exciting check this out the first
500 people who see this video and go to
david pakman.com slash skill will get a
premium membership to Skillshare for two
months completely free skill shares the
online learning community with thousands
of classes on almost anything you can
imagine always taught by experts they
have classes on drawing painting
photography video editing web design
running a small business and much more i
recently took a very interesting class
called simple productivity how to
accomplish more with less and got a
bunch of great personal productivity
tips out of it we should allow ourselves
a little time every week to either get
creative keep your brain sharp learn
something new it's great for mental
health and almost all the classes are
under an hour so it's very easy for
someone who's busy to take advantage of
it with skill share you can discover a
new passion explore something you didn't
know you would enjoy but there's also
plenty of classes for people with
experience so you can just get better at
something you're already good at and
again the first 500 people who see this
video and go to david pakman.com slash
skill will get a completely free premium
membership for two whole months giving
you access to every class Skillshare
offers check it out i put the link right
underneath this video